[Music]
my name is gabby i'm a
jewelry specialist and certified
dimetologist at jared the gallery of
jewelry so today i'm going to show you
how i clean a few pairs of earrings and
get them going from dark and dull to
bright shiny and just like new again
so
this particular pair the solitaire
earrings we'll take the earrings over to
our digital gym scope where i can get an
up-close look at them
these had
a good bit
more than your average amount of build
up within not only just the setting but
actually the backs as well
with this pair i use a
very sharply pointed needle to remove a
lot of that excess buildup so
typically with earrings a lot of what
you see is shampoos
and conditioner
and
in this one it does appear as though
there was
some ear wax and then after that and
i've removed as much as i can with the
needle i take it over to our ultrasonic
where i'm going to go ahead and let
these soak in here for probably about a
minute or so
the liquid that's in there it's a mild
alkaline type solution it's just
designed to break up anything that's
built up upon the piece now i'm going to
go ahead and take it over to our high
pressure steamer
where i can remove any bits of debris
that are left over after letting it soak
in the ultrasonic
and then after that my favorite part is
getting a nice close-up look at them
after they've been cleaned
so this particular pair of solitaire
earrings are definitely a well-loved
pair of earrings
so what i did was
started by removing all of this earwax
and hair product buildup that is trapped
inside of not only the backing of the
earrings but the setting and all the way
down the post of the earrings they were
absolutely covered
so this pair of earrings that this guest
brought in were in white gold with three
little diamonds set on them it just
looks like your typical shampoo and
conditioner build up that has been
caught in all the little openings of the
earrings
so luckily metal and of course diamonds
being the hardest natural substance on
earth i don't have to worry too much
about causing any damage when using this
needle something that i do like to do is
make sure that i am going through at
every possible angle
for the most part earrings especially
stud earrings are a staple in just about
everyone's jewelry box
and when they're worn every single day
like this for years or months on end
eventually all of the stuff that we
encounter is going to get caught up on
there and it is going to make them dirty
without routine maintenance and
cleanings on them they definitely all
could reach this point
this is a cluster style earring gives
you a nice big look this earring here
actually hadn't been cleaned and i
believe she said a little over a year
and not only that but after she lost the
other earring this one singular one had
just kind of been sitting
collecting dust allowing all of that
buildup to just sort of
cake together so you can see on the top
of this one here there is
a lot of
earwax and product that's built up
covering up those stones leaving a film
on them now something that did make that
does make this setting a little bit more
difficult
than a simple solitaire setting is that
this setting here has a lot of detail
work
up underneath where it can be more
difficult for me to actually get the
tweezers in there to remove
a lot of this stuff so for the most part
i'm really going to be counting on the
ultrasonic and the steamer more so than
on solitaire earrings or another style